Let's see if we can calculate 5/6
Plus 1/4, and to help
I have a visual representation of 5/6
And visual representation of 1/4
Note I have a complete unit
I think you can say
He divided into one, two, three, four, five, six
Sections, and we have five of them shaded
Thus this represents 5/6
Also we have below the other complete unit
We have one shaded section of the four sections
Thus this represents 1/4, now we want to collect the fractions
I encourage you at any time to turn off the video
To see if you can find out for yourself
Well, every time we collect fractions we have to think
Do these fractions have the same place
It is clear that these two fractions do not have the same place
But in order to re-write their common denominator
We just have to think about the common multiplier for six and four
Ideally, consider the smaller common multiplier for six and four
The way I prefer it to do that is
To take the larger number of them, which is the number six
And then think about its complications
I think of the first six
Obviously, the six are divisible by six
The six are indivisible on the four, and now let us multiply it
By number two, we will get number 12
12 can be divided into six and four
So 12 is the best common place here
12 is the yellow multiplier of the six and four
Thus we can rewrite the fractions as numbers
On 12
Thus the number on the 12
Plus number
On 12
Equal
Now, there are a range of ways to address them
But what I want to do is to see it here
In this drawing
So if you go
Or if I had to turn from
If I had to move from six equal sections
To 12 section is equal, which is what I do
If you go from six in the place to 12
In the place
I will multiply all these sections by
Or, I will multiply the number of sections
Which I have number two
Or I will take each of these sections
I convert it into two parts
let's do it
Let me see if I can do this accurately
I can do a little better than that
So it will look
And ,
Oh
Let me do this
I want to divide it fairly evenly
I'm doing it so given it would not be perfect
And we also have this
Then finally and not
Last but not least
And then notice
I had six sections but now I have twice as many
sections
You converted the six sections to 12 sections by conversion
Each of the six basic sections into two, so I have
One, two, three, four
Five, six, seven, eight
Nine, Ten, Eleven, 12 Section
If I have 12 departments, how many of these twelve
They are now shady
Instead of having five shaded sections of six, I now have
Ten shaded sections of 12
Thus, I now have 10/12
5/6 is considered as 10/12
There is another way to think about it
They are moving from six to 12, beating in two
Then I have to do the same thing in the rugs
Five in two equals ten
It is hoped to see that these two fractions
Equal
Because I did not change the shaded part
I just took each of the six basic sections and turned them around
To two, or you multiply the total number of sections
By number two we get 12
And then put it instead of 5/6
I now have 10/12 section shaded
Now, let's do the same with the four
With 1/4
I have a conception here about 1/4, but I want to turn it into
Number on 12
Thus converting it to a number of 12
Each section must be divided into three sections
let's do it
Let's turn each section into three sections
Thus, this is one, two, three
Then we have one, two
And three
I have
Believe that you can see where this happens
One
Two, three
I have one, two, three
And you can see that all I did was multiply
In the past I had four equal sections
Now, I convert each of these four sections to three
Sections, now I have 12 equal sections
And I did it by multiplying the number
The sections I had were three
Now what is the fraction that represents the shaded part
Well, that's the origin
Who was one of four, we can now see that he became three
Out of 12 equal sections
It is now three out of 12 equal sections
Therefore, what will be
If we collect 10/12 to 3/12
Well, how much is part of our dozen
I'll get 13/12
And you can see it visible from here
Here in green, I have 10/12 section shaded
Each of these funds is part of 12
Let me write it down
Each of these funds represent 1/12
This represents 1/12
Thus, how many sections shaded from 1/12
We have ten sections shaded in green
And then we have 11/12
12/12 and finally
13/12, this is one way to think about the subject